Or
if 100 million people are
going to vote for him,
if they do indict him,
you're going to get 120 million people
voting for him
because they're just, you know,
you can't take an honest man down.
The new weapon
being used by out of control,
unhinged Democrats to cheat on election
is criminally investigating.
A candidate
for.
I think if he's arrested
and indicted, it's going to help him.
So go for it.
It doesn't change
a thing about his integrity
and everything else.
We all have seen
we all have some things that we've done.
We are a nation that has weaponized
its law enforcement
against the opposing political party
like never before.
If he wants to get indicted,
I think it'll just
bring more people come in here
on Trump side.
I think it'll help.
I think it will happen now, definitely.
Because it's not right.
It's just not right.
He's going to have more press time.
His face is going to be out there
more often and all that.
And Trump's a fighter,
so he's going to make it through this.